nous sommes à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines à l'occasion des 10
ans du village sportif et culturel
et si vous pouvez découvrir plein
d'activités des nouveaux sports des
expositions allez on y va du hockey sur
gazon de halle escalade ou encore du
volet 27 activités sont proposées à tous
et gratuitement cet été près de 3200
jeunes vont en profiter pendant trois
semaines un plaisir pour les centres de
loisirs
c'est super cool c'est super intéressant
et yappa il ya plein de plein
d'activités proposées n'ont pour
l'instant on les a pas toutes faites
on espère et
et voilà on reviendra c'est sûr c'est
important parce que ça contribue au
travail que l'on fait avec sur toute
l'année
faire découvrir du sport tous les sports
en général mais presque la quatrième
année convient essayez donc et c'est
génial
pour cette édition anniversaire des
nouveautés le basket le breakdance la
réserve naturelle mais aussi une
sensibilisation à l'environnement
nous sommes avec vincent couteau
responsable communication événementielle
de l'île des loisirs
bonjour bonjour donc c'est les dix ans
de ce village sportif et culturel tout à
l'heure de faire un petit bilan
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en dix ans ici
pas mal de choses finalement puisqu'il
ya dix ans on était installés au coeur
du parc promenade avec multitude de
tente c'était l'ufolep qui avait géré la
première édition à l'époque ensuite on
s'est installés juste derrière là quand
la piscine était ouverte donc au fond de
la piscine de l'espace qui aujourd'hui
l'espace événementiel
puis quand le bassin à fermer bah ça on
s'est étalée on a pris la place on s'est
vraiment développée sur l'ensemble de
l'espace plein air est donc aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a un beau village qui a
lieu sur quatre hectares plus les
activités des loisirs
et qu'est ce que ça représente pour
saint quentin en yvelines ce village
alors c'est vraiment un très beau
dispositif c'est maintenant ancré dans
l'agenda de toutes les structures
jeunesse et enfance du territoire et
d'île de france puisque on accueille des
structures du 93 du 95 voire même de 77
pour certaines et vraiment localement
c'est une date clé que tout le monde
attend donc enfin mais on commence déjà
à voir des coups de fil pour savoir ce
qui va y avoir comme activité qu'est ce
qu'on les nouveautés quand aura lieu le
village
donc on est on est très très contents de
l'organiser puis ça permet de donner
vraiment de du renouveau des activités
de nouvelles sur l'île des loisirs pour
pour sortir des activités habituelles
qui fonctionne bien mais qui sont à
l'accrobranche la voile équitation qu'on
va faire toute l'année ça fait dix ans
que vous êtes là qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter pour les dix ans à venir
et ben village encore plus beau encore
plus grand encore plus d'activités que
ça puisse perdurer et que ça puisse
garder sa vocation c'est à dire la
mixité sociale la mixité culturelle
les initiations aux gestes qui sauvent
la partie culturelle qui est importante
aussi
et puis peut-être une sensibilisation
accrue à l'environnement comme on l'a
fait cette année
et si vous voulez venir à lille de
loisirs ça se passe du lundi au vendredi
de 10h30 à 13h30 jusqu'au 6 août
prochain pour entrer il faut se munir du
pass sanitaire qui est entrée en vigueur
depuis le 21 juillet